y
[Música]
jornada de terror en kabul capital de
afganistán al menos dos ataques suicidas
mataron alrededor de 60 civiles afganos
y 13 militares estadounidenses dejando
decenas de heridos estos atentados
reivindicados por el autodenominado
estado islámico ocurrieron en cerca del
aeropuerto donde miles de personas
siguen intentando salir del país
presidente de eeuu joe biden se refirió
a los hechos que se produjeron hoy en
afganistán uniéndose a varios líderes
europeos involucrados en la zona del
ataque todos condenaron los atentados
asegurando que a pesar de la situación
continuarán con las evacuaciones de
civiles extranjeros y aparatos
y en guatemala la ocupación hospitalaria
supera el 140 por ciento a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 y la nación más
poblada de centroamérica son los embates
de la tercera ola de contagios que ha
tomado fuerza con la variante delta y
también con la variante lambda
circulando en el país apenas el 6% de la
población está vacunada tenemos análisis
volvemos con más información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en las 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia iniciamos en
afganistán donde el autodenominado de
estado islámico atacó el aeropuerto de
kabul la capital con dos atentados
suicidas por ahora funcionarios
talibanes y también estadounidenses
confirman unas 60 víctimas civiles y 13
militares norteamericanos además de
decenas de heridos tanto los líderes
occidentales como los propios talibanes
condenaron el atentado y también a
continuación repasamos para ustedes
tecnología los hechos y las principales
reacciones internacionales en este
reporte de mar romero sal
ya habían pasado las siete de la tarde
en kabul la capital afgana cuando una
explosión retumbó en la puerta a videla
aeropuerto casi a la vez otro estallido
cerca del hotel barón
poco después el pentágono aseguró que se
trataba de dos ataques suicidas con
bombas el caos se apoderó del aeropuerto
donde miles de personas esperan ser
evacuados testigos y periodistas
reportaron una verdadera masacre con
decenas de muertos y heridos
eeuu confirmó que hay militares
norteamericanos entre las víctimas
casi simultáneamente a la una de la
madrugada el estado islámico se atribuyó
el atentado
los talibanes condenaron el ataque y
recordaron que habían advertido del
peligro de tener aglomeraciones en el
aeropuerto pasada la una se reportó otra
explosión sin embargo poco después los
talibanes confirmaron que se trataba de
una explosión controlada de las fuerzas
estadounidenses para destruir munición
varios líderes internacionales
condenaron los ataques y letizia la
tensión muchos buque es obvio que la
atención aumento demasiado todos
conocíamos este riesgo desde el inicio
dada la confusión en kabul y la atención
en el aeropuerto militar usando el grupo
militar las próximas horas seguirán
siendo 'extremadamente riesgosas en
kabul y en el aeropuerto
siempre supimos que este era un momento
en el que por supuesto iba a haber
vulnerabilidades particulares del
terrorismo weekend en un accidente nos
condenamos creo que son despreciables
pero me temo que son algo para lo que
hemos tenido que prepararnos esto no va
a interrumpir nuestro progreso vamos a
continuar
puedes
eeuu también ha confirmado que seguirá
adelante con la evacuación
el presidente de eeuu joe biden también
se expresó durán se expresó después de
las explosiones que dejaron decenas de
muertos en el aeropuerto de kabul el
mandatario reafirmó que a pesar de la
dramática situación en la zona las
tropas estadounidenses saldrán del país
a más tardar el 31 de agosto
el presidente saliente hizo un trato con
el talibán
que todas las fuerzas estadounidenses
saldrían de afganistán
no vamos a dejarnos determinar por los
terroristas no vamos a parar nuestra
misión vamos a continuar con la
evacuación
y órdenes para atacar al estado islámico
en afganistán a sus líderes y complejos
vamos a responder con fuerza y precisión
en nuestro tiempo y cuando nosotros los
dispongamos en el módulo board sushi
tal y como algunos temían el grupo de
estado islámico está detrás de los
ataques suicidas en el aeropuerto de
kabul su auto denominado califato fue
desmantelado en irak pero el grupo
todavía tiene combatientes activos en
varios lugares de oriente medio y asia
en afganistán estados las llegadas
radicales que se declaran enemigos de
grupo talibán ya han cometido varios
atentados
se refieren a ellos mismos como estado
islámico de jorasán y xisca en honor al
nombre histórico de la región que
incluye partes de pakistán irán
afganistán y asia central
meses después de que declararan un
califato en irak y siria en 2014
luchadores desencantados de los
talibanes de pakistán y de militantes
afganos crearon la versión regional de
este grupo terrorista
el estado islámico se estableció en
afganistán contando con los que estaban
decepcionados con el talibán algunos
comandantes militares muy conocidos
prometieron fidelidad al estado islámico
fueron formalmente reconocidos por los
líderes centrales después de
establecerse en las provincias de kunar
la envergadura y stan en el noreste de
afganistán son enemigos declarados de
los talibanes ya que consideran que su
visión del islam no es suficientemente
dura
expertos en seguridad estiman que su
número de combatientes puede ir desde
los 500 hasta los 2.000 los ejércitos
europeos y de eeuu creen que los
integrantes del issys que operan gracias
a células secretas basadas en las
ciudades han logrado llevar a cabo
varios ataques de alto perfil en el país
inmediata en kabul ya han realizado
varios ataques en kabul muchos mortales
usando carros con explosivos caseros y
hasta bombardeos con cohetes el líder
como el último ataque contra el palacio
presidencial antes de la victoria del
grupo talibán fue el estado islámico
quién lo hizo
en noviembre pasado atacaron la
universidad de kabul también se cree que
son responsables de un atentado contra
un pabellón de maternidad en un barrio
predominantemente chiíta de la capital
habitado por la minoría hazara y en mayo
un carrobomba mató a 80 alumnas a pesar
de no controlar ningún territorio en la
región se sabe que el grupo se mantiene
activo y es peligroso y que busca
ampliar sus filas con yihadistas y con
personas descontentas con el dominio
talibán
en eeuu un grupo de siete agentes de
policía que fueron atacados y golpeados
durante los disturbios en el capitolio
el pasado 6 de enero presentaron una
demanda contra el ex presidente de
donald trump
los uniformados acusan a trump y sus
seguidores de enviar intencionalmente
una turba violenta a las instalaciones
del congreso la demanda fue interpuesta
ante la corte penal en washington ante
la corte federal y alega que trump
trabajo con sus demás istas blancos y
grupos extremistas para cometer actos de
terrorismo interno en un esfuerzo ilegal
por mantenerse en el poder
hablamos ahora de guatemala donde la
tercera ola de la pandemia de ccoo y 19
no da tregua el sector hospitalario
registra un nivel de ocupación del 140
por ciento según autoridades sanitarias
los profesionales de la salud están
desbordados y han protagonizado varias
manifestaciones durante las últimas
semanas pasen plano nos comunicamos con
el doctor gerardo hernández director
ejecutivo del hospital general san juan
de dios de guatemala centro médico donde
trabaja es uno de los más grandes y
también uno de los más colapsados del
país a causa de la pandemia que nos
describió la situación de los pacientes
y también del personal médico si en
efecto pues el hospital que nosotros
dividimos es uno de los más grandes a
nivel nacional y en este momento el
hospital tiene una situación que es muy
característica que estamos viviendo una
doble función porque atendemos pacientes
cubrir pero también atendemos pacientes
no kobe y eso nos ha llevado a un punto
en donde estamos ahora en esta
saturación en este cansancio del área
hospitalaria de los médicos debido a que
nosotros estamos en este momento
sirviendo para
para las dos situaciones hoy por hoy
tenemos aproximadamente por arriba del
130 por ciento de ocupación en nuestro
área de campamento de cubrir y pues el
área de severos ha estado pues bastante
por arriba del porcentaje de 1.000 que
éste lo habíamos diseñado entonces
realmente en estos momentos y los
médicos están cansados ya están en un
síndrome de burnout y nosotros realmente
administrativamente es complicado poder
tener todos los instrumentos y dad con
que se están consumiendo dentro de
nuestros hospitales
también le preguntamos a qué se debe la
lentitud en la vacunación y en guatemala
donde sólo un 6% de la población ha sido
inmunizada esto fue lo que nos dijo
la vacunación inició de una forma muy
lenta debido a que el sistema kóvacs no
nos había entregado como de bien es
entregado y como estaba planificado
luego se hicieron algunas compras a
nivel de como el gobierno de rusia para
entregarla sputnik v y nosotros hemos
estado pues esperando y cómo nos van
entregando haciendo esas entregas
parciales que hemos estado recibiendo
entonces la lentitud con que estamos
recibiendo este estos embarques de las
vacunas pues nos ha dificultado poder
hacer esta situación gracias a ellos
tenemos muchos países hermanos que nos
han donado la vacuna y hemos podido ir
avanzando en la vacunación hoy por hoy
ya está reportado con primera dosis más
o menos cuatro millones y medio de
guatemaltecos
esperamos poder avanzar más en este en
estos momentos y también hemos estado
invitando a la población a que se pueda
vacunar debido a que también hemos
tenido un poco el problema de que no han
querido acudir a la vacunación en
algunas partes de guatemala y nos ha
costado mucho algunas reacciones pues
según creencias no han querido aceptar
la vacunación y eso lo que estamos
tratando en estos momentos
por último nos explicó cuáles son las
solicitudes del sector de salud al
gobierno nacional para evitar un colapso
peor aún en el sistema sanitario
bueno específicamente lo que necesitamos
es una tregua con el virus pueda plantar
esa curva que estamos en estos momentos
es tan complicado queremos poder
disminuir los casos en estos momentos y
la verdad es de que estamos tratando y
pidiéndole a la población que se cuide
nosotros estamos tratando hacer hasta lo
imposible dentro de los hospitales
necesitamos más personal médico más
personal paramédico de terapistas
respiratorios que es una situación tan
complicada en guatemala que no hemos
tenido suficiente y pues estamos
tratando de que esa situación podamos
solventar la con este tipo de
contrataciones para darle un respiro al
personal que actualmente está debemos de
apostar a la vacunación y que esto
avance para poder mejorar pero también
la población debe hacer su parte ya que
están muy relajados están haciendo
fiestas están haciendo reuniones y eso
nos está sobre con complicando debido a
esta variante del está que ha ingresado
que es mucho más efectiva que está
haciendo que la infección corra más
rápido dentro de los pueblos y eso nos
está llevando al colapso que tenemos en
estos momentos
cada año son más de 50 millones las
personas contagiadas por el dengue y más
de 500 millones están en situación de
riesgo con la llegada del coi 19 los
diagnósticos de la enfermedad se
volvieron más complejos debido a la
similitud en los síntomas pero parece
que hay una solución la bacteria
wolbachia que reduce drásticamente la
población de mosquitos responsables de
la enfermedad nos lo cuenta juan
fernando el bid
sigue la guerra contra el dengue en el
día internacional de la lucha contra
esta enfermedad mortal se recordó que el
virus transmitido por el mosquito aedes
agypti no se ha ido lo peor es que los
casos subieron estos últimos años y con
el coronavirus se complicaron los
diagnósticos antes la impresión es que
los casos de dengue se están diluyendo
dentro del propio kobe porque muchas
veces la sintomatología es similar como
dolor en el cuerpo fiebre dolor de
cabeza en brasil se pronostica que entre
2022 y 2023 los casos de dengue aumenten
significativamente para poder luchar
contra la proliferación del mosquito
aedes agypti hay prevenciones básicas
pero desde hace unos años se implementó
en 11 países la bacteria wolbachia entre
colonias de mosquitos que tiene como
propósito impedir la transmisión del
virus un mosquito que además de
transmitir el dengue también transmite
el cica el chikungunya y la fiebre
amarilla en indonesia donde se
implementó la bacteria se anunció en
junio que los casos locales de dengue se
habían reducido en un 77 por ciento una
esperanza para luchar contra esta
enfermedad que infecta cada año a más de
50 millones de personas en el mundo
como país tropical indonesia cuenta con
varias zonas donde viven que se volvió
un problema permanente después llegó el
cob y entonces es una doble condena para
los habitantes de esta región
estas dos enfermedades pueden ser
mortales sean mitos a mahatma fatal en
el papel y lo que preocupa más a los
expertos es el crecimiento de casos
entre los niños más vulnerables frente
al virus según el reciente índice de
riesgo climático de los niños de unicef
115 millones de niños están expuestos a
la enfermedad
el líder opositor ruso alexéi navalni
dio su primera entrevista desde la
cárcel donde permanece detenido desde
enero pasado aseguró que los presos
políticos son sometidos a presiones
psicológicas también reveló que es
obligado a ver la televisión estatal
durante más de ocho horas al día con
películas de propaganda pro rusa nada ni
hablo con el periódico estadounidense
'the new york times' al frente del cual
también eso estuvo que el régimen de
vladimir putin está a punto de
derrumbarse
y mañana viernes 27 de agosto france24
en español y sus cadenas hermanas en
árabe inglés y francés tenemos una
programación especial dedicada a la
situación de las mujeres en afganistán
sus conquistas durante los últimos años
y lo que se atendrán a perder ante el
nuevo gobierno talibán entre otros temas
habrá invitados especiales y análisis de
expertos a lo largo de toda nuestra
programación no se lo pierdan aquí
entradas 24
nos vemos más adelante con más
información aquí quédense con nosotros
[Música]